um so I'm going to talk about why and
how decaditis get things wrong the kind
of the subtitle this talk might be why
data scientists suck so I've probably
already broken the uh in terms of the
conduct but of course all right
um I'm going to give you four case
studies of projects that I've been
involved with and how and why they went
off to rails and I think there are
General lessons for data scientists as a
whole which I'll talk through what they
are
um three main errors uh we'll come back
to these letters I'm not listening to
customers right and we'll see an example
of that actually in the first one and
some others I'm putting computational
techniques over business outcomes right
and again we'll see a little bit more of
that and then using the wrong methods
now one of the rules of presentation is
you shouldn't introduce new material in
the conclusion but I'm going to do that
here right just just because I can right
um okay first of our case studies is
churn prediction and if you don't know
what churn is typically for a SAS
companies when customers leave right and
for SAS company churn is a huge problem
there are targets if you want to go
public you have to meet them blah blah
blah in this case the customer success
Department needed to reduce churn right
and they wanted to intervene and prevent
it so they came along to the data
science department just before I got
involved with them right and they asked
for a model to be built here's the data
set that was available uh Salesforce
data so it was the account name the
location the industry the deal size
um all those things right lots and lots
of information
and there was churn data for thousands
of accounts right going back over 10
years also product usage data right so
separate from the Salesforce data so the
product was very well instrumented and
so it's who does what and when and for
how long right all the features they
were using and so on right summary lots
of datas and lots of features so my
first audience question so let's see if
this works who how might you solve this
problem and would you build a machine
learning tool to do it any thoughts any
comments I don't buy it most of the time
so it's okay
any comments
through the classification of renewal or
not
anything else I'm going to take a few of
this is this worth building a machine
learning model for
the answer it depends uh
different answers here right now I mean
I come from computer vision which is
completely useless for this type of
problems
all right I'll Skip and I'm going to ask
this question a number of times so
different case studies right so yeah I'm
not going to tell you to pieces if you
get the wrong answer
um okay so what's missing this data is a
leading economic indicator right so you
get churn for a period of time let's say
stable economy then the economy has a
downturn but your model will predict a
lower churn and will actually be seen
and conversely as you get recovery so
the model lacked any kind of external
economic data right the team that did
this just weren't aware that that was an
issue I'm very dumb right the other
thing is that the customer success team
was not involved in the development of
the project that's really really bad
right it went off the rails very quickly
and never got back on the rails right
because they needed to be involved all
the way through and the team didn't
think about how they were going to
display the information they were oh
well to this wonderful machine learning
model and it will do this or how is it
going to be consumed by customers right
didn't think about that I generally
speaking customers don't want models
they want Solutions right now to go back
to the famous Netflix example of the
recommended system Netflix don't give a
damn about recommended systems right
what they're trying to do is get you to
watch more of Netflix programming right
so that's the ultimate goal okay I and
in this case that's crucially important
right so what happened here customer
success need causality so you can't just
say to them oh well you know
um customers in the midwest defense
companies in the midwest are sucking
right now because having a bit of a
downturn what how can they act on that
what can they do they can't change the
customer they can't change them from
defense to being retail or something
else that can't happen right you can't
change the location you can't change the
deal size so if you tell them that churn
is likely to happen all you're saying to
a salesperson effectively is your life
is going to suck over the next few
months and maybe you should go and find
another job somewhere else right this is
not a good message to transmit to
somebody right it's unactionable data
conversely the product usage data is
actionable right so there are things
that you can do if you see the customers
aren't using a certain feature you can
do webinars you can intervene you can go
into push-up product usage you can look
at licensing usage you can look at
passive usage all kinds of things that
these guys know how to do
so realistically when it came to it what
they were after was not a machine
learning model to predict churn but
basically a model not even a model but a
simple alerting system on low product
usage right so we have something that
the deliverable was greatly different
from really so the team had already
committed to build a model but in
reality that's what was wanted so it's a
question of not listening to customers
all right so let's have a look at the
next one oh so okay so this is a
personal project EPL is English Premier
League right so it's football or we say
soccer here right so this is a personal
project can you predict the results of
EPL matches right so I had a go at this
I had uh the Premier League was founded
in about 9294 but you can go back about
100 years before that there's enough
data to do it
um so loads of data transfer values
foreign bottom players attendance
figures blah blah blah blah loads of
data loads of features so let me ask
everybody that same question would you
build a machine learning model to do
this how would you solve this problem
and you want to take a crack
what's the name of this movie about
American baseball volleyball label in
space this what this is yeah I was
trying to make myself rich
didn't actually work so you know the
answer is already but anybody want to
take a crack yeah
okay
I'll answer this for you right so here's
what I did
um I used eight different models right
through the analysis and frankly the
results sucks right I had a a naive
predictor and I was comparing it against
that and I outperformed the naive
predictor but not enough basically to
make any money on gambling and so like
you know in the past I had been part of
a gambling Syndicate right that did
actually make some money right so this
time but that was in the UK not here so
anyway when I talked to people and said
well you know how can I make this better
what can I do so certain number of data
scientists what should I do here and
they said well have you tried more
models
well I tried eight different models
right trying more models probably not
going to work right it's not an
effective thing but everybody said try
an ensemble model right so think about
the Ensemble model right so I've just
told you that my results sucked but what
you're saying is we're going to add
together a couple of models that suck to
make one bigger model that's slightly
less right so I mean maybe it would have
worked but none of the models actually
gave me any particularly good results
anywhere right so so Ensemble model
isn't going to work
very very few people disappointingly
told me to go and get more data right
now it would actually have been possible
to go back and Define extra fields that
I didn't Define I did do some
unsupervised learning that didn't give
me anything either but yes more data I
think actually would have made a
difference here right and it would have
helped me boost the other thing that
nobody at all other than me suggested
was killing the project
the project is probably because there's
too much Randomness underneath right to
really produce an effective model right
and the proof of this almost as if you
turn on the TV look at any sporting
event how many people lead with are
computer models are predicting a 3-2 or
what whatever the victory is Nobody Does
it right now you think there that if
this was the case if these models
actually worked very successfully then
you would expect that to be the case
right so it's a kind of an existence
proof but let me ask people how many
people in this room have been part of a
data science project that was canceled
because the underlying data was just too
random for models to work
anybody else
isn't Randomness good for this isn't
that yeah but if it's Randomness it's
predictability right and if you have a
truly random system you can't predict it
right it is not this understandable
distribution that can predict there's no
underlying logic right
um so look think about that think about
we've got two people in the room who've
experienced a project that they've
canceled right in my case I canceled
right
um
don't you think that should figure
should be a bit higher
right so I'm asking you guys to think of
the projects that you've worked on do
you think around this room that there
should be more hands going up people
saying yeah aren't the like systems just
a little bit too random for this to work
so have a think about that
um okay so let's go to the next one
I think I remember what Ensemble method
is but can you refresh yeah so typically
you take like a couple of models right
so I said glm CNN SVN whatever right now
what it might be that under certain
conditions some of these results gave
okay results in other conditions they
gave poor results the idea would be to
kind of Bolt these two models together
and say over this range we're going to
use this model and over this range we're
going to use that model or even just add
the results together somehow somehow
combine them in different ways yeah my
memory was that Ensemble means that you
take the error of the first model and
you apply a second model to the error
and chain them this way model on the
error and then you get another error and
you get the third model yeah you can do
that you could you could
think I see so it's good to know thanks
yeah so there's different ways of
combining the models but bear in mind
each time you bring another model is
computational cost as well and that's
one of the reasons why the Netflix
solution The Prize winners was never
implemented because the cost was too
high in computational time for the
benefit okay
um sales prospecting all right there's a
little bit of sales team running through
this rice kind of you know um okay so in
this case the sales and marketing team
came to me and they said we need to
improve our prospecting process right we
need to be able to focus our team and
where they're making their calls
um can you help us so we know Salesforce
data which is location industry uh all
kinds of details about company turnover
blah blah blah all those things uh we
have a lot of lead generation data we're
having enough data and features and
customer sales and marketing team
sitting in the room well virtually
because it was post-pandemic right
they're sitting in the room guiding this
right so this customer involvement all
the way along right enough data and
enough features
any my two questions here would you
build a machine learning model to do it
yourself of them you want to take a
crack
you might run into the whole search into
the light post problem here because
you're rolling out of data for where
they've tried to sell before
so you won't have data where they
haven't tried it
um so I don't know which key question
I'm answering yes but this interaction
in a second
anybody else want to have a crack at an
answer
okay
um actually I thought a machine learning
model was actually a potentially a great
solution here right I thought this was a
really great thing to do so I had
somebody on my team do it and this is
what happened right uh they built the uh
machine learning model right but the
problem they ran into it's not like the
I think is it search post or lamp post
problem yeah yeah it's not that but what
we found is that there were problems for
data right so the Salesforce data was
missing data one of the key Fields
actually was a categorical variable that
should have had about 30 different
variable numbers in it or values in it
it actually had 700 because things had
been mislabeled right in Salesforce
um too much mistaken diversity uh
wrongly data etc etc right
um so the model didn't converge right so
the data scientists working on this more
and more computing power into it
right so what would you do in that
circumstance
abandon the project
yeah I killed the project right and the
the marketing CMO was really really
angry but the CEO told me I did the
right thing right because there was just
no realistic Prospect of success
so one of the things I do see with data
scientists doing right and I got some
real pushback from this so just carry on
carry on carry on all right but there's
no point at some point you would look at
projects and it's just not going to work
right so it's time to kill it move on to
the next thing
okay so this is
um all the other ones have been fairly
directed with what happened this one
I've had to change the details a bit
because it would identify the company
too much so but this is the closest I
could get it right so it's responses to
fraud it wasn't really fraud it was
something else but it's close enough to
get you there
um so the problem was we were trying to
decide are businesses who suffer fraud
likely to suffer more fraud or less
fraud in the future right so there's two
arguments one is that if you suffer
fraud you're going to improve your own
internal processes which will make you
less vulnerable in the future the other
one is that you're a bit slack right
which is why you got hit by fraud
therefore you'll be slack in the future
therefore you'll have no fraud in the
future right so two competing arguments
right and the goal was to decide on the
face of it which of those two arguments
was actually correct so actually were
companies who suffered a fraud were or
less vulnerable all right so the data
set here was complete in the sense we
didn't need any external economic
indicators for loads and loads of
business data we had the fraud
prosecution results right we knew all of
that uh data complete all the data and
features enough you know millions of
data points it's all fine and the
customer in this case marketing is fully
engaged
so let me ask my question
anybody want to take a crack would you
build a machine learning model how do
you tackle this problem
and the data is high quality data yes no
Pro Data quality problems at all this
project actually worked
yeah
like longitudinal so you get each
individual like business each point you
know all the businesses at different
points in time and you know whether they
were fraud free or not right so as I
said it's not Ford it's actually
something else but the equivalent of
that
do like a hazard model
anybody else want to comment
because you're the per you're going to
know the results
the same right like that's like if you
have millions of observations probably
it's not millions of businesses it is
millions businesses it was 12 million
plus businesses oh yeah okay so I
answered my own question right so
there's a push from the team to do it
like my team they want a few people
wanted to do machine learning and I said
no that we were not going to use machine
learning for this what we did is
difference in differences right
um and it's a crazy experimental
technique and the project actually
succeeded and it succeeded very well
right so we got the publication out of
it we actually took it to Congress and
we did a whole bunch of other things for
the results
okay so let's go back to the three main
sources of error like not listening to
customers right huge source of problem
right that happens when the customer
isn't in the room and you're off doing
your own thing and thinking all about
you know basically always this you know
XG boost or something right right but
not talking to the customers figuring
out what they want uh computational
techniques over business outcomes
when you sit down in your groups and you
discuss how often do you discuss what
the customer wants and how much do you
discuss the computational techniques and
add a guess you're there discussing
techniques way more than the business
right to be my guess and then lastly
using the wrong methods right okay so
maybe the wrong model the wrong uh uh
whatever okay so how can you protect
yourself against this right so uh listen
to your colleagues right sales reps I
know they don't have phds and they don't
master's degrees and all those things
right but they have years and years of
experience and they can sell and you
can't right so go and listen to them
right and listen to the relationships
and what they want
um product look you know let's be honest
right we're all adults here product are
a variable quality right the product
teams right some good some bad
um if you get a good product person they
are you know a proxy for the customer
right but sometimes basically they're
just product project managers so just be
careful about what you've got in terms
of the way of a product person
um what's the true business goal right
back to that Netflix example and back to
my example about the churn model what's
really wanted here and they might tell
you that they want to model because
that's sexy and it's wonderful and all
the rest of it right but really is that
what they want right so there's usually
an underlying problem and the product
people should help you do that
um but often they don't right so you
have you can't rely on them alternative
approaches and we've talked through this
right so it's not just using difference
and differences on machine learning or
whatever right there are other cases so
I had a problem where I needed to go and
get a whole set of data labeled and
people were saying well let's go and do
a machine learning problem and just
label it right and I said no I had a
college student and got them to go and
basically label the data by hand and it
was cheaper to do that than machine
learning right so I'm asking you to
think a bit more flexibly about you know
not everything is a machine learning
problem not everything you can actually
pay people to go and do stuff like this
and you can go out to low-cost countries
and have people do it and then the last
thing here is what's your projectile
criteria so think for the projects that
you're working on when would you kill
the project right and I know I'm like a
bit happy to kill projects right and all
the rest of it but for you guys think
about this what would cause you as a
manager or whatever it is to go and stop
your project and allocate the resources
elsewhere so you should know what that
is and at least certainly the person
running the project should know that is
so my final thought is to be less wrong
think more like a business person and
less like a doctor scientist
so that's it folks thank you all very
much
[Applause]
let me ask why a difference in
difference is not a machine learning
approach uh I I think so maybe this is
just me I just think of machine learning
as
um
as being a different category of things
right yeah so I mean it might just be
semantics you think it's it's machine
learning I don't that's fine I don't
really matter does it yeah I mean yeah
yeah it seems like a machine learning
solution was there right actually one of
the things that we have right and
company I work for needs to show more
machine learning more stuff so if you
think if you're telling me that
difference in difference cancers machine
learning I gotta count it right because
we need it for our marketing department
yeah absolutely AI let's say whatever
right how does the difference in
difference work roughly speaking talk to
him
so the idea is um yeah
closet experience after we have a
control group that looks similar to your
treatment and you want them to have like
linear Trends they don't have to be
exactly the same
um and then the online assumption is
that post-treatment the trend would
happen if they would follow the same but
what you do is you measure the
difference pre-treatment then you
measure the uh post-treatment difference
and then take the difference of those
two differences and that difference is
the treatment effect or the intervention
yeah yeah synthetic controls is a little
similar to it it doesn't have as much
like underlying
um
parallel trans assumption uh but again
it's and you don't need to have a as
good of a look-alike treatment group
um so like I think can't it was card and
talk to Kruger yeah they use uh how what
they do is they look at differences in
wage minimum wage going up in New Jersey
and they used a budding Town that's in
Pennsylvania so they should look almost
identical and economically and they were
what was the effect of increasing
minimum wage on unemployment like the
measure they didn't find anything that's
good yeah there's another one can't
think the other authors
I was thinking of snow in 1854.
[Music]
yeah yeah I've just read that in uh that
the book of why was that thing was that
book yeah
foreign
the kill like why not because I feel
like I'm just thinking about the one
that you like we killed one we didn't
kill it we like changed its trajectory a
little bit
so the EPL one I might come back to that
right I've still fantasize about
whatever you're in the Mediterranean
right and going back to my gun fixing
ticket so it might be possible to do
something right it just needs to be
recast but I needed to walk away from
that for a period of time that was a
personal project right
um so it's easy to do the other project
that I killed which is the Salesforce
one and it was but the prospecting look
realistically to fix the data would have
required a great deal of effort there
was no money to do it right so the data
scientists around the table if I said to
you when you're going to spend the next
month fixing Salesforce data errors
right and I think there'd be a massive
Revolt right so you know it's it's not
right and even if if that data those
things were fixed there was still other
problems as well right so again it's you
know is there a realistic like oh like a
legal test is there a realistic Prospect
of success and in this case I just
didn't think that there was at all right
Paul I mean it was easy for me right
being the boss where I can do it
um but you know for other people as well
I recognize this kind of stuff it's
quite hard to do but for you for your
own survivability right if you're
working on a project and you can have
doubts it's time to start looking for
another job I mean better to look for
another job before you're kicked out
right because somebody kills the project
for you right so you should always be
aware right about the realistic
prospects of success
yeah
come on
so with your EPL model do you just use
like did you use any like individual
Player information like of flags of how
they've been performing over the last
three games a story like uh no so that's
that's a good so you can do that right
but you pay an arm and a leg for that
data right
um and I I've been a cheap study I just
decided I could get off the screen
oh my God I love that
um but actually one thing I did find
right so there's a home team effect
right and there's always a thought right
in in any kind of competitive sport
right but the home team has an advantage
and you clearly see that during the
pandemic the home team effect just went
away completely right gold difference
just dropped to zero and then you go
back in and you look before that you
look after and it's like half a goal per
game right it's the home team effect but
it's absolutely crystal clear and I
found that but I never published it and
I saw somebody at an academic
institution published it and I thought
damn if I'd have just had a bit more
faith in myself
but never did
um but yeah for that kind of stuff right
getting this the data is difficult right
and I I said Aaron you can go back 100
years which you can right but there's no
foreign-born data set Beyond right I
think some people started it in about
2000 transfer values well you know maybe
this that was people starting recording
that in the 80s right you go back to the
1950s How many
right so there's a question some of this
data is available
um
I I'd like I'm gonna probably at some
time I'm gonna have another go at this
right just out of interest to see if I
can actually do any better
but yeah I mean at some point you do
need to kill projects
I was thinking that I'm really curious
about is like like you have all these
like tablet features like numeric
features categorical features like have
you ever thought about like Translating
that into text and then trying to like
transfer learn from the language models
like
you know to see the language model like
with the representations it has from all
that if that would help it predict it
like
I don't know to be honest right I'm
rethinking some of this I'm also
rethinking things about promotion
relegation which goes on in in the EPL
and capturing that but I hadn't thought
about using Tech stuff at all
you'll be curious how that would
intersect with a causal inference stuff
I think try to put those two together
would be really something
yeah it could just be the sporting
events are just too random worthwhile
prediction but there is a talk that
highest scoring games like basketball
and other things right they might be
easy to predict in most scoring games
seriously yeah it was really interesting
uh
what's named Silver's outfit
538 yeah they did they did one on their
Premier League predictions and they know
how I think they stop giving guesses at
like five minutes right yeah because
they say it's so random but yeah that
there's you know because one goal can
change so much yeah so that was what
they really discussed a lot is that
they're you can make predictions as much
as you want but because it's such a low
scoring game that one event kind of
essential origin okay yeah they also
talk about like the importance of which
variables you're using so it is uh
possession percent on its own it's not
very effective we saw that with Jim
papers Germany I think where it's
actually possession in the defense of
third or offensive yeah it's far more
predicted so it's also just like having
these metrics a subset of the soccer
problem is like the penalty kicks yeah
this is what the goalie where do they
jump left or right that's what they saw
the um
shooter she's left or right and they
both know the other guy is statistic and
the question is how do they do it but he
knows that he knows yeah and now they do
like after like when if you watch the
politics like wondering again they'll go
to the manager and they'll start talking
which way they're going to know yeah
depressingly actually when things I
found is the clubs of the most money
when the most often right which is which
is you know hardly a shocking result
right
but it is it is a depressing result but
it's there